Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Blinkist.
Seguro que, al igual que a mí, muchas veces
tienes la sensación de que no te da el tiempo
para ponerte a leer tantos libros como te
gustaría o como solías hacer. Exámenes,
trabajo, al final siempre hay algo que se
acaba interponiendo, ¿o me equivoco?
Bueno, pues qué me dirías si te dijera que
existe una app que te resume en 15 minutos
miles de libros de no ficción en inglés
de todo tipo, y no solo en texto sino también
en formato de audio.
Pues el caso es que esa app existe y tiene
un nombre: Blinkist.
Una de las cosas que más nos soléis pedir
es que os recomendemos libros, pues en Blinkist
encontraréis muchos de los que siempre os
decimos: apuestas seguras para todos los que
seguís VisualPolitik son por ejemplo, Factfulness
o Por qué fracasan los países, también
están Pinker, Taleb, apuestas seguras; o
si os gusta el mundo de la inversión tenéis
nada menos que El Inversor Inteligente.
Los primeros 100 de vosotros que vayáis a
blinkist.com/visualpolitikES tendréis acceso
ilimitado por una semana para probarlo totalmente
gratis, si no os convence podéis cancelarlo
sin problema durante esos 7 días y en caso
de que os guste, disfrutaréis también además
de un 25% de descuento para un full membership.
Chile era el país más estable y más próspero
de América Latina.
Todo un modelo a seguir. Una especie de experimento
para demostrar que incluso en Latinoamérica
escapar de la pobreza no es una meta imposible.
Sin embargo, en Octubre de 2019 todo este
sueño comenzó a romperse en mil pedazos.
De repente enormes olas de violencia y gigantescas
movilizaciones políticas estallaron por todo
el país.
En apenas unas semanas, el país estaba en
llamas.
(Desde que arrancaron las protestas 26 personas
han perdido la vida; los heridos se cuentan
por miles, más de 25.000 locales han sido
afectados por incendios, saqueos o destrozos,
el metro de Santiago ha sufrido daños por
valor de cientos de millones de dólares y
la economía se ha parado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según los datos
del gobierno los daños económicos se sitúan
entre los 2.000 y los 3.000 millones de dólares.)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, en este
vídeo os contamos qué diantres ha pasado
en Chile, por qué ha ocurrido y que viene
por delante.
Atentos.
(LA LLAMA QUE PRENDIÓ LA MECHA)
La explosión social de octubre fue una sorpresa
que pilló a todo el mundo desprevenido.
Fijaos, el punto de inflexión se produjo
cuando el gobierno chileno decidió incrementar
el precio de los billetes del metro de Santiago
en 30 pesos, unos 4 centavos de dólar.
Sí, lo sé, no era precisamente un gran incremento...Pero,
amigos, digamos que esa fue la excusa, la
llama que prendió la mecha.
De repente cientos de estudiantes comenzaron
a protestar entrando en el metro sin pagar…
pero la cosa no se quedó ahí.
Poco a poco se desmadro del todo.
Fijaos, estamos hablando del lunes 14 de octubre,
pues bien, para el Sábado 19 el metro ya
estaba en llamas:
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
La mitad de las estaciones del metro de la
capital habían sufrido ataques vandálicos
y más de 20 estaban ardiendo, literalmente.
Estaban siendo reducidas a cenizas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, tan solo los
daños provocados en la jornada del sábado
19 se estiman en 200 millones de dólares.
(Piñera anuncia el estado de excepción en
Chile tras fuerte explosión de violencia
por la subida de las tarifas de metro. El
Mundo)
Pero ese no era más que el comienzo. En los
días sucesivos la cosa se puso aún peor
y las protestas se extendieron al resto del
país.
(De repente, supermercados, tiendas, autobuses,
incluso edificios enteros fueron víctimas
del vandalismo y los saqueos.
Chile ya no se parecía a Chile, al Chile
que todos teníamos en mente. Grupos tremendamente
radicalizados querían terminar con el llamado
“modelo chileno” a golpe de revolución.)
Por supuesto, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
en un primer momento, la policía no se andó
con chiquitas y respondió con fuerza, con
mano dura.
Y sí, puede que hayas escuchado todo lo contrario,
pero lo cierto es que sobre esta cuestión
las principales organizaciones de derechos
humanos coinciden:
desde el Alto Comisionado de las Naciones
Unidas para los derechos humanos hasta organizaciones
como Human Right Watch han recopilado pruebas
y acreditado como en muchos casos los cuerpos
de seguridad chilenos, los carabineros, se
excedieron y se extralimitaron en el uso de
la fuerza.
Datos del propio Ministerio de Salud: los
servicios de urgencias atendieron a más de
11.500 personas como consecuencia de las manifestaciones.
De todas ellas, 1.100 - que se dice pronto
- presentaban lesiones moderadas o graves.
Y no solo eso, hay más de 350 denuncias , sobre malos tratos, torturas
y abusos hacia los detenidos.
(“Factores como el uso indiscriminado e
indebido de armas y escopetas antidisturbios;
abusos contra personas detenidas y sistemas
de control interno deficientes facilitaron
que se produjeran graves violaciones de los
derechos de muchos chilenos. José Miguel
Vivanco, director para las Américas de Human
Right Watch)
(Protestas en Chile: informe de la ONU reitera
que se han producido un "elevado número"
de violaciones graves a los derechos humanos.
BBC)
En cualquier caso, para no equivocarnos
aquí hay dos detalles muy importantes que
tenemos que tener muy en cuenta:
Primero, con esto no queremos justificar en
absoluto la acción de los violentos. Para
nada, ¡Todo lo contrario!
Estos grupos radicales, violentos, agresivos
que merecen toda nuestra condena no tuvieron
ningún reparo en atacar a los propios carabineros
con piedras, bancos y con todo lo que pillaran.
Incluso con cócteles molotov. Por no hablar
de los saqueos, los robos, las intimidaciones,
etcétera, etcétera.
("Ellos también han sido víctimas de estos
hechos de violencia, de hecho al día de hoy
tenemos más de 2.500 carabineros heridos
o lesionados, algunos de ellos de gravedad"
Sebastián Piñera)
Pero, por otro lado la mayoría de los manifestantes
se comportaron de forma pacífica y muchos
sufrieron las consecuencias de una policía
que simplemente no estaba preparada para lo
que se les estaba viniendo encima.
(Chile: Llamado urgente a una reforma policial
tras las protestas
Uso excesivo de la fuerza contra manifestantes
y transeúntes; graves abusos en detención.
Human Right Watch)
Y es que nos penseis que las protestas en
Chile han sido cosa solo de unos pocos radicales,
para nada.
El 25 de octubre es un día que pasará a
la historia de Chile. 11 días después de
estallar las revueltas 1,2 millones de personas,
de acuerdo a las estadísticas oficiales,
se echaron a la calle para manifestarse contra
la situación del país, contra el rumbo del
país. ¡Ojo, que hablamos de más de más
del 20% de la población de Santiago!
Así que llegados a este punto lo que tenemos
que preguntarnos es, ¿realmente están justificadas
protestas de este tipo en el país más próspero
de América Latina?
Pues amigos, ya os adelanto que aquí tenemos
una cal y otra de arena.
(30 AÑOS, CÓMO HA CAMBIADO CHILE EN 30 AÑOS)
Empecemos por la mejor cara.
“No son 30 pesos, son 30 años”.
Este ha sido el lema principal de unas protestas
que poco a poco han ido justificándose por
la elevada desigualdad que padecen los chilenos
como consecuencia de ese sistema que ha imperado
en las últimas 3 décadas.
Pero… amigos, ¿realmente ha sido tan malo
este periodo de tiempo?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
Fijaos en cómo ha evolucionado, por ejemplo,
la pobreza:
Chile ha pasado de ser uno de los países
más pobres de Latinoamérica a luchar por
la primera plaza de los más ricos y más
desarrollados.
De hecho si nos fijamos en el índice de desarrollo
humano, que además de variables económicas
incluye otras como la atención sanitaria,
la educación o por ejemplo la esperanza de
vida, Chile se sitúa en el primer puesto
regional.
Respecto a si hablamos de desigualdad, es
verdad que Chile tiene mucha desigualdad,
pero no es cierto ni mucho menos que sea el
país más desigual de Latinoamérica, para
nada.
En cambio si que es uno de los países de
la región donde más se ha reducido la desigualdad
en los últimos años.
[Lo siento, no es culpa mia, son los datos.]
Y es que de hecho si en vez de fijarnos en
la desigualdad total, nos fijamos en los niveles
de desigualdad entre las personas que están
en el mismo rango de edad vemos cómo la
desigualdad es mucho menor entre las generaciones
más jóvenes.
Es algo similar a lo que ocurre con la educación.
(Si echamos un vistazo encontraremos que Chile
tiene un porcentaje de población con educación
secundaria inferior a la media de la OCDE.
Pero… Si en cambio nos fijamos en que ocurre
con los chilenos que tienen entre 25 y 34
años, entonces estos ya superan el promedio
de los países más ricos.
Y no es algo extraño, es una característica
muy habitual de los países que han crecido
muy rápido. Es fácil encontrar características
muy diferentes entre la población según
la generación a la que pertenezcan. Una parte
habrá crecido y vivido en un país pobre
y la otra en un país desarrollado)
Pero tal vez la mejor forma de aproximarnos
a todo este jaleo sea de la mano de Rodrigo
Valdés, ministro de Haciendo en el segundo
mandato de Michalle Bachelet.
[Vamos, que no hablamos de ningún libertario
precisamente]
Pues fijaos, en 2018 este buen señor presentó
un paper en la Harvard Kennedy School dónde
venía a decir dos cosas:
Primero, que la izquierda es estaba equivocando
de cabo a rabo en en empeñarse tanto con
el tema de la desigualdad porque para combatirla
el crecimiento económico era mucho más importante
que la redistribución.
Y segundo, que en los últimos 30 años los
que más han visto incrementada su renta han
sido precisamente los más pobres. Mirad:
Vamos, en otras palabras, que lo que el país
necesita sobre todo es más crecimiento económico.
Y por ahí vienen en cierto modo los problemas.
Porque ya os he dicho que teníamos una de
cal y otra de arena.
¿Tienen los chilenos motivos para quejarse?
Atentos.
(MOTIVOS PARA EL DESENCANTO)
Amigos, que muchas cosas hayan marchado bien
no quiere decir que los chilenos no tengan
motivos para sentirse defraudados.
Defraudados, esa es la palabra. A los chilenos
se les prometió unos resultados que no terminan
de llegar.
A pesar de todo lo que hemos visto hay cosas
que…. Bueno, no son tan positivas.
(El país tiene un nivel de productividad
muy bajo que sigue lastrando los salarios,
más de tres quintas partes de toda la población
clase media vive en el límite, es vulnerable
a perder por cualquier circunstancia sobrevenida
ese escalón.
Y la economía, otra hora el gran orgullo
de los chilenos ya prácticamente no crece,
no al menos en términos per cápita. Los
últimos años están siendo bastante pobres.)
Y, claro, si la economía no crece y los salarios
reales tampoco crecen… Pues… Eso que la
cosa no va por buen camino, ¿no os parece?
Y no solo eso, las pensiones - otra de las
grandes promesas que se le hicieron a los
chilenos - son muy bajas. Para que os hagáis
una idea la mitad de las pensiones que se
pagaron en los últimos meses apenas recibieron
123 mil pesos, unos 160 dólares al mes.
¡Una auténtica miseria!
Y ojo, que os conozco a muchos de vosotros.
No es que el sistema de pensiones de capitalización
de Chile sea malo, para nada.
Lo que ocurre es que los ciudadanos por un
lado no lo conocen, porque no se les ha explicado
debidamente como funciona, y por otro lado
el gobierno ha hecho una dejación de funciones
casi total.
(Por un lado no ha controlado que los tiempos
de cotización fueran adecuados y por otro
lado no se preocupó de establecer una mínima
red de seguridad para aquellas personas que
no lograron cotizar lo suficiente.
La combinación es explosiva, porque supone
que la gente entiende que un buen sistema
es un mal sistema porque las pensiones que
reporta son muy pero que muy bajas.
Y es que fijaos, tal y cómo está montado
el sistema es una bomba de relojería. Los
hombres se jubilan a los 65 años con apenas
18 cotizados de media. Y el caso de las mujeres
es aún peor, se jubilan con 60 años y 13
cotizados de media.)
¿Qué que han hecho el resto del tiempo?
Bueno… economía informal, acuerdos bajo
la mesa para no cotizar, etcétera, etcétera.
Y vamos a ver. ¡Cómo se pueden soportar
20 o 30 años de jubilación si solo se han
contribuído 13, 15 o 18 aportando sólo el
10% del salario! Es que no se puede, es imposible
que las pensiones sean más altas. Pero por
este motivo.
Y con un sistema de reparto la cosa a medio
plazo podría ser aún mucho peor.
Si no se cotiza el sistema simplemente no
funciona, ni de una forma ni de otra.
Y si a todo esto le sumamos la sensación
de que las divisiones sociales siguen muy
presentes en la sociedad…. Ahora ya podemos
entender la enorme frustración que alimenta
las protestas.
[Aunque la verdad es que si lo pensamos un
momento parece un poquito injusto que se focalicen
contra un presidente que ganó las elecciones
hace muy poco tiempo.
Más aún, cuándo de los casi 30 años de
democracia en Chile, la izquierda que ahora
forma parte de las protestas ha gobernado
prácticamente 25. Hombre, algo habrán tenido
que ver con el modelo, ¿no os parece]
El caso, amigos, es que las expectativas no
se están cumpliendo.
Y en cierto modo es algo que se explica con
la conocida como Ley de Wagner, una tesis
que defiende que a mayor riqueza mayores son
las presiones para que el estado suministre
más y más bienes sociales.
Y claro cuánto más pequeño sea el estado
más fuerza tendrá esta dinámica.
Pero, ahora la pregunta es, ¿Y ahora qué?
(LA SALIDA DEL TÚNEL)
En fin, creo que ahora podemos entender mucho
mejor que ha ocurrido en Chile durante los
últimos tiempos.
Pero la pregunta es, ¿Tendrá salida este
problema?
De momento, lo que está haciendo Piñera
son dos cosas:
Por un lado poner en marcha una agenda social
que entre otras muchas cuestiones incrementará
las pensiones más bajas y establecerá un
ingreso mínimo vital.
Es decir, las personas que trabajen y no alcancen
los 350 mil pesos verán cómo el gobierno
complementa sus nóminas.
Por otro lado se ha acordado que en 2020 se
le preguntará a los chilenos acerca de si
quieren cambiar su constitución. A pesar
de que la constitución chilena ha sufrido
219 cambios desde que se produjera la transición
democrática.
El último importante en el 2005:
(“"Este es un día muy grande para Chile.
Tenemos razones para celebrar. Tenemos hoy
por fin una Constitución democrática, acorde
con el espíritu de Chile. Ricardo Lagos,
Presidente de Chile entre el 2000 y el 2006)
Pues se equivocaba porque al parecer ya no
vale. Y que queréis que os diga. Más allá
de que no es recomendable andar cambiando
de constitución todos los días ni generando
falsas expectativas, lo que Chile necesita
es concentrarse en volver a crecer, sólo
así podrá superar de verdad todos los problemas
a los que se enfrenta.
En fin, espero que con este vídeo podáis
entender mejor todo lo que ha acontecido durante
los últimos tiempos por el país sudamericano.
Desde VisualPolitik estaremos muy atentos
a cómo discurren los acontecimientos.
Ahora, abramos debate. Espero vuestros mensajes
en los comentarios.
De nuevo, gracias a Blinkist por apoyar VisualPolitik,
Muchas gracias a vosotros por estar ahí como
siempre.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.
Gasto Público